[Music]
plastic waste is piling up in the
world's landfills sewer systems and in
the ocean plastic pollution is
destroying life in the ocean a gigantic
swell of trash floating in the Pacific
Ocean and human Coastal
communities we see plastic everywhere
some of the places being hit hardest are
small island States small island
developing States contribute minimally
to a lot of environmental challenges but
impacted the most so what do these
countries reveal about the problem and
the answers urgently needed to solve
[Music]
it on a small island in Fiji Sam is a
fisherman who depends on the
sea my community connection with the sea
is it's our daily life the majority of
fiji's Po population live near the coast
and many are all too aware of an
increasing Scourge in the water plastic
pollution when we go to the Sea even the
coral you'll see the Plastics there the
fish that usually stays in the coral
they are not there anymore now and
usually the fish we catch you can catch
it now there's a lot of plastic it's
been poluting our ocean a
lot I think Fiji has definitely changed
uh due to plastic pollution I believe
that it going to bring uh many problems
in the
future Fiji is part of a group known as
small island developing States or SIDS
these islands have a combined population
of just 65 million and suffer the
consequences of plastic pollution
disproportionately that's because
plastic pollution damages the industries
their economies depend on fishing but
also
tourism a lot of the plastic waste that
washes assure small island developing
States affect our tourism we're dealing
with small economies already vulnerable
to so many environmental challenges
climate change rising sea level and
economic
growth globally humans produce around
350 million tons of plastic waste per
year
a figure projected to almost triple by
2060 it's estimated around 11 to 14
million tons ends up in the ocean so how
is this plastic getting into the
[Music]
water some does come from small Islands
per person the Caribbean is one of the
highest emitters of plastic to the
ocean the challenge for small Islands
across the world is overflowing and
unregulated landfills like these with
limited space dump sites are often close
to the coast and the main option for
getting rid of
waste there are leakage issues because
of unsound waste management and low
resources there's limited land space for
landfill capacities and low resources
for recycling which leads to an
acceleration of the plastic waste in
country but most plastic pollution in
the ocean is not coming from small
Islands Pacific island countries produce
less than 1.3% of the mismanaged
Plastics in the world's oceans yet are
one of the main
recipients a lot of plastic pollution
washes up on the shores of small Islands
because of ocean currents and I'm
interested in the Dynamics of how the
ocean actually moves Professor Eric Van
seil was one of the first to use
simulation like this to show how and
where currents lead to hotpots of
plastic in the
ocean we developed simulations of how
the ocean currents move plastic from one
location to the other location what we
see is that a lot of the plastic stays
near
Shores and then some of the plastic
eventually ends up in the centers of the
what we call the subtropical gers there
are five of them one in the North
Pacific one in the North Atlantic and
between the South Pacific the South
Atlantic and the Indian
Ocean large areas of the ocean and many
coastlines are badly affected but his
research backs up the idea that many
small Islands suffer especially from
plastic pollution so I think that seeds
are particularly impacted by plastic
pollution and that's both on the effect
that it has on their local economies but
also because those seids are in the
middle of the ocean there where there's
a lot of plastic floating around that um
may end up on their
Coastline the SE shells is a group of
islands in the Indian Ocean which are
particularly affected by ocean
currents on the alabra atel one of the
country's largest Marine protected
areas scientists from Oxford University
collaborated with the SE shells Islands
Foundation to collect data on the source
of
pollution as you can see
the beach Crest is absolutely covered in
Marine
debris because alabra is not inhabited
we know that none of the plastic that's
arriving on alabra is actually coming
from
alabra this simulation created by the
scientists shows how debris enters the
ocean from countries such as Indonesia
India and Sri
Lanka some of that debris makes its way
to the SE shells via ocean
currents the scientists also found
another big source of waste on alabra
Industrial fishing we found the majority
of waste by weight was from the
industrial
Fisheries big ropes Nets boys um
discarded
barrels the team removed 25 tons of
rubbish but estimated this was just 5%
of the total amount on the island one of
the biggest things that we noticed was
that the turtle nesting beaches was so
clogged with plastic that it was
actually putting the turtles off from
nesting
there the whole of SE shells is impacted
by plastic
pollution and this is a global problem
that's arriving on their Shores on a
scale at which they're not able to deal
with although the fishing industry is a
major cause of this Global problem
research suggests the biggest sources
are rivers in polluting countries in
Asia those studying the hotpots in the
ocean say tracking the different sources
of this pollution is vital it means the
polluters can be named and shamed one of
the things that I really want to do with
the simulation is run them in backward
mode and then essentially play the blame
game and then we can assign a
probability a chance that it comes from
say a certain River from a certain
Fisheries area from a certain country
then we can maybe maybe maybe start
thinking about litigation and really get
the blame game into
court but what are islands themselves
doing to get rid of plastic in their own
backyards there's one simple and obvious
thing Beach
cleanups these are now common on Islands
across the world and they also help in
ways that the naked eye cannot see and
every time that plastic goes back and
forth on the sand on the rocks that is
where microplastics are actually created
and that means that cleaning up
coastlines is actually the most
effective way to clean up the ocean then
you prevent it from getting back into
the ocean as
microplastics countries can also go
further and ban some ways that Plastics
are used one tiny Pacific island has led
the charge
here Vanuatu was one of the first
countries in the world to enforce a
single-use plastic ban and it now has
some of the toughest plastic
restrictions in the world in 2018 it
banned items such as single use plastic
bags plastic straws and takeaway
containers with more items added to the
lists since since a band there is a big
chance before we have many plastic bag
but now we have none Regina is a local
Weaver who says she is benefiting from
the bands by selling bags made from
alternative materials such as the leaves
from local trees when we free the
plastic Pikes in develop my business
with our country free from the Plastics
we can do many different kinds of things
more apart from
this and on vanuatu's beaches Dr
Christina Shaw has measured the success
of the
Bands so that's um fishing line so you
get a um sort of everything mixed up
together and then
Tangled
four during Beach cleanups band plastic
items now make up 2% of recorded litter
before the bands that figure was 25 to
35% I think one of the big things um
that some of these small island nation
has done is actually stepped up and made
the decision they go no it is a problem
we're going to ban these Plastics we're
going to do what we can do um and I
think that is a lesson for the bigger
governments as well however it's near
impossible for any country especially
inhabited small Islands to survive
without any plastics it's difficult for
small island nations to be completely
plastic free cuz we're not in control of
the whole life cycle of plastics all of
our Plastics are important
by far the biggest um item we have is
plastic food packaging so you know your
noodle rappers Lolly wrappers um chewing
gum wrappers we're relying on the
Innovations in other nations and other
big companies um to to make so that it
makes it easier for for us to to try and
become plastic
free now more than 120 countries across
the world have bans and taxes on various
single-use Plastics these include big
countries such as India and Canada as
well as small islands in the Pacific
Caribbean and Beyond and while this has
brought some reduction in waste Banning
Plastics can pass the but switching to
Alternative materials can create other
waste
problems so it's vital to get better at
reusing and recycling
Plastics globally only 9% of plastics
are recycled 19% incinerated 22%
mismanaged and 50% end up in
landfill on small Islands recycling is
tricky because they lack the
infrastructure and space it requires
sending waste abroad often long
distances and that's
expensive we know we need to develop
recycling capabilities I think we need
to talk about the resource needs the
gaps the challenges and the Avenues for
support if we were to ever solve this
problem and there's another much bigger
Global challenge here current recycling
methods even in rich countries are a bit
rubbish most Plastics can only be
recycled two or three times before they
become unusable and end up in
landfill to solve The World's plastic
problem what's needed is a new
technology to improve recycling one that
depends on work far beyond the shores of
small
Islands what we really need is a
recycling process that takes that
material back into virgin like
properties so that it can be used in the
original application again and again
professor John mcgean and his colleagues
have been working on just that a whole
new approach to recycling at the
University of Portsmouth on Britain's
South Coast they have been identifying
and Engineering what are known as
plastic eating enzymes these can break
Plastics down into their original
component molecules which can then be
used in infinite
Cycles what we're looking for is more
circular um technologies that can really
generate the building blocks and allow
us to infinitely use that material again
teams of researchers across the world
are searching for these enzymes that can
break down common Plastics many are
looking in pollution hotspots like
Indonesia and the Philippines and also
on small islands like Singapore the best
place to look for enzymes that can
digest plastic is places like uh beaches
corals and particularly mangroves places
where there's High areas of of plastic
pollution we've been working with
colleagues all around southeast Asia
particularly based in Singapore where
there's groups there that can go out
into the field and in those areas we're
starting to see enzymes that are
developing evolving that can eat the
Plastics eles and we can actually then
bring them back to the laboratory
identify the enzymes and then engineer
them to be
faster plastic eating enzymes have great
potential to reduce waste although the
technology is still a long way from
being used at a global scale and from
overcoming the infrastructure challenges
link to current recycling practices we
need to develop technologies that are
scalable but also are Deployable uh into
the areas where plastic pollution exists
and we think that's possible we think we
can actually miniaturize some of the
solutions so that local communities can
potentially um degrade Plastics and and
get chemicals out of those that they can
then sell and actually give back to the
local
economy plastic pollution is ultimately
the world's
problem and new levels of global
cooperation are needed to solve it
although small island states have led
calls for Action richer and larger
countries will determine whether this
happens we will have a strong Global
International and comprehensive
framework on plastic pollution in 2022 a
UN resolution was signed by 175
countries committed to developing a
global legally binding Plastics treaty
by the end of
2024 this promises to cover production
packaging design and disposal of
plastics but for now it's just talk and
no walk without coming together we're
going to see fragmented approaches we're
going to see a proliferation in this
issue that would lead to unsustainable
levels of plastic pollution we're
hopeful the treaty will make a
difference but it has to be strong
enough to do
[Music]
so